un 11 avril 2019 qui restera dans les
mémoires avec ces images d'une
arrestation totalement ubuesque ce
jour-là et julian assange est appréhendé
après sept ans passés dans l'ambassade
d'équateur à londres un responsable
lenin moreno le président équatorien à
nos cieux aujourd'hui j'annonce que le
comportement disgracieux et agressif de
monsieur julian assange les déclarations
hostiles et menaçante vis-à-vis de
l'équateur des organisations qui le
soutiennent et surtout la violation de
traités internationaux ont conduit la
situation un point tel que l'asile de
monsieur assange est insoutenable et
n'est plus viable et fiable
c'était prévisible tout d'abord les
lignes moreno incarne une ligne très
droitière bien plus proche des
etats-unis que l'était son prédécesseur
rafael correa issu des rangs de la
gauche
son arrivée au pouvoir elle n'augure est
donc rien de bon pour reviennent assange
dont washington a juré la perte
et ça n'a pas loupé dès sa prise de
pouvoir en 2017 lenin moreno a tout fait
ou presque pour rendre l'asile politique
de julian assange à qui ils reprochent
de mettre l'équateur dans l'embarras par
ces commentaires invivable coupure
internet instauration d'un règlement
intérieur drastiques dans l'ambassade
les conditions de vie l'australien
deviennent déplorable il ira même
jusqu'à accuser julian assange de
piratage un événement va précipiter la
rupture entre les deux hommes le site
wikileaks met au jour une affaire de
corruption dans laquelle moreno et sa
famille seraient impliqués pour le
président c'en est trop le président de
l'équateur lenin moreno a déclaré
aujourd'hui qu'assange avait violé les
conditions de son asile et qu'il
prendrait une décision prochainement
après que wikileaks a parlé du scandale
de corruption in apple qui éprouvent son
gouvernement
neuf jours plus tard vous connaissez la
suite julian assange est expulsé de
l'ambassade est immédiatement arrêté par
la police britannique pour avoir violé
les conditions de sa liberté provisoire
il est détenu à la prison de haute
sécurité de belmarch dans le sud de
londres
parmi ses nombreux soutiens l'ex
président équatorien rafael correa a
désigné son successeur comme le plus
grand traite de l'histoire latino
américaine même son de cloche en france
où jean luc mélenchon qualifie moreno le
larbin des états unis mais rien et me la
justice britannique
un qui impose aux prévenus des
conditions de détention extrêmement dur
qui impacte sa santé mentale comme
physique on a vu un homme extrêmement
attaqué par la situation qui résistent
très dignement qui se tient fier et sans
arrogance face à la violence à laquelle
il fait face mais qui souffre évidemment
très violemment de des conditions de sa
détention qui sont proprement inhumaine
et assimilable à de la torture il est
enfermé 23 heures sur 24 il n'est pas le
seul à s'en préoccuper dans une lettre
ouverte plus de 60 médecins du monde
entier alerte sur les dangers de son
incarcération
l'onu parle même de torture
psychologique
les soutiens aux populaires politiques
associatifs se multiplient à travers le
monde
la france est en première ligne et les
gilets jaunes notamment qui se
mobilisent et organisent des voyages
réguliers dans la capitale du royaume
uni en janvier 2020 débute une longue
bataille judiciaire pour assange la
justice britannique reprend l'examen de
la demande d'extradition des etats-unis
atteignant son statut de journaliste ou
de lanceurs d'alertés washington elle
souhaite juger à julian assange pour la
diffusion de centaines de milliers de
documents confidentiels
en vertu des lois anti espionnage mais
la procédure judiciaire patine entravée
par la santé déclinante du prévenu et la
pandémie du commis 19
c'est en septembre 2020 que le procès
reprend reporters sans frontières suit
attentivement les quatre semaines
d'audience
ses conclusions sont sans appel nous
sommes convaincus que julian assange est
poursuivi pour ses contributions au
journalisme et que cette affaire
constitue en réalité une application
politique de l'espionage act
ce qui en soi devrait empêcher son
extradition
le 4 janvier dernier la justice
britannique rejette la demande
d'extradition de washington
raison invoquée le risque que le système
carcéral américain ferait peser sur la
santé du cofondateur de wikileaks
une victoire au goût amer puisque julien
assange n'est pas remis en liberté ne
serait ce que temporairement car les
autorités américaines ont immédiatement
notifié au tribunal britannique leur
intention de faire appel
purge aucune ni fait tourner à à
répondre de rien devant la justice dans
sa position actuelle
donc pourquoi est-il en prison creps la
vie entre quatre murs se poursuit donc
pour julian assange à belmarsh une
histoire sans fin surtout quand on la
vit derrière les mains